the jurogan experience the
2017 new york times article uh in my
mind made
that was a big shift because when the
new york times is reporting about it and
saying that this is major news and this
is real and there's
video evidence that they can't ignore
when you talk to high-level people at
the government and people like commander
david fravor who had that
infamous spotting off of the coast of
san diego when you hear about people
like that that are very reputable it
starts to change the conversation in a
lot of people's eyes right it used to be
that one person would see something in
the sky and say look martha look there's
something up there
now things have changed now we have
multiple sightings by multiple modes
that is the gold standard the gold
standard for looking for these objects
not just one person but several people
that are reputable not just radar but
visual sighting infrared sensors
telescopic evidence now we have multiple
sightings by multiple modes and so the
burden of proof has shifted it used to
be the burden of proof was on the people
who believed in ufos they saw something
prove it
now the burden of proof has shifted to
the pentagon to the military now they
have to prove that these aren't
extraterrestrial
and so i think there's been a sea change
a sea change in the last uh just several
years you know 50 years ago there was a
congressional hearing
and it was coming out of project blue
book
and there was a lot of laughter and a
lot of jokes about things little green
men in outer space 50 years ago that's
the way it was now
things have changed now people are
looking at
looking at are they a threat militarily
what kinds of sensors do we have what
kind of metrics do we have
we now have frame by frame an analysis
of these objects these objects travel
between mach 5 and mach 20 that's 20
times the speed of sound
these objects can zigzag
and we can measure the g-force inside
the this object the g-forces are several
hundred times the force of gravity in
other words any living person's bones
would be crushed by these objects so
they're probably drones of some sort
these objects can drop seventy thousand
feet in a few seconds think about that
it can drop a tremendous distance in
just a few seconds and
they can go underwater
this is something that we didn't realize
before but yes they could actually go
underwater
and they also move without creating an
exhaust or breaking the sound barrier
so these are things that we can now
document frame by frame looking at these
videotapes
so for yourself what was the shift and
how did you feel about ufos say like
10 15 years ago
well there is this giggle factor and
it's the third rail of course of your
scientific reputation
if you believe in these things but the
evidence is accumulating over the last
several years now when i was first
approached by caroline corey the
producer of this film a tear in the sky
i was skeptical i said to myself come on
i mean five days five days you're going
to look for flying saucers in the sky
what happens if the aliens are camera
shy and they don't show up in five days
so i was pleasantly surprised when they
actually found something they actually
have photographic evidence of objects
that can gyrate just the way the
pentagon has said and so we now have a
sea change a center of gravity has
changed with regards to looking at these
objects we no longer simply look at one
individual seeing something in the sky
no we demand hours of videotape multiple
sightings by multiple modes that's the
gold standard now so what do you think
is happening do you think that this is
something that maybe
another government from another country
has created that far surpasses our
abilities or do you think that this is
coming from somewhere else well the
pentagon has listed i think five
different options uh one option of
course is that they're weather balloons
or something that's an artifact of our
space program
maybe a piece of rocket that is is
plunging back into the earth's
atmosphere
uh that's one category another category
is anomalous
weather events
they happen and they have to be looked
at very carefully but the last option
the last option is other
that is not just the russians or the
chinese because these objects apparently
can generate faster than what the
chinese and the russians can muster but
it opened the door to the possibility of
other they didn't specify what other was
but you can fill in the dots yourself
now one possibility for other is
hypersonic drones we see that in warfare
now the russians in the battle of
ukraine is actually using hypersonic
drones to hit targets inside ukraine
to be hypersonic you have to go faster
than mach 5 anything faster than five
times the speed of sound is called
hypersonic and so the russians are now
fielding hypersonic drones in warfare
but you see this is something just in
the last few months
these sightings they go back decades
into the past
with objects executing these gyrations
decades ago and that's why you have to
take them seriously so the commander
david fravor event that we talked about
off the nimitz that was 2004.
do we have an accurate understanding
about military capability in terms of
like drones and propulsion systems from
2004 or are there things that are
classified that we are not going to have
access to like is it possible
that you know 18 years ago they had the
capability
to have a vehicle or a drone move this
way
that just that information has just not
been released
well two years ago the united states
military admitted that it stopped
working on these hypersonic drones why
they're unstable they zigzag and that's
why the russians have put a premium on
this technology to evade our star wars
program
the russians wanted a rocket that can
maneuver
and therefore outwit a stationary star
wars system designed to shoot down
these drones right so that's why the
russians have put a priority on this and
they've now fielding in warfare we
actually see them as a military weapon
two years ago the united states military
stopped its program they're too unstable
they they were not reliable and it was
not worth the amount of money to put
into it because the military was
invested in the star wars program not
the anti-star wars program but because
vladimir putin announced the hypersonic
drones that the united states military
said oops nope we have to get into the
game too so now the united states is
also working on hypersonic drones as
well as the chinese so the chinese the
russians and americans are all working
on these things but you can see how
primitive they are
we're talking about objects that define
the known laws of aerodynamics with the
technology beyond what we have today
and so that's why people are scratching
their heads
whose are these things if they're not
the chinese the russians or the united
states
so
one of the main
points of contention is
the lack of visible propulsion method
right there's no
it essentially there's no heat signature
there's nothing that we understand to be
present that normally exists when
something is going at a tremendous rate
of speed that's right not only that
these objects create no sonic booms
when you exceed the sound barrier uh you
create a gigantic boom that is then
shatters windows and can be heard miles
around these objects can effortlessly
break the sound barrier and not create a
sonic boom and they don't create any
exhaust
we don't see any exhaust trail from
these objects so either they're an
optical illusion of some sort
or they have a set of laws of physics
beyond what we what we can muster now if
they are
a optical illusion
if an object were to move in front of
your eyes traveling at a very slow
velocity
but you don't know how far they are away
you may think that object is very far
away from you traveling at enormous
velocities
so a weather balloon drifting in front
of your eyes
can simulate an object traveling at
hypersonic velocities if you think that
weather balloon is far away from you
so how do you tell the difference well
you look at wind patterns it turns out
that many of these sightings these
objects defy the direction of the wind
if they are weather balloons that you
confuse with a flying saucer
then they would be moving with the
direction of the wind but these objects
do not do that these objects can go
against the direction of the wind not
only that but we have multiple sidings
if an object is very very far away and
if an object is close to you but you
think it's far away then it then is
traveling at an enormous velocity while
it's actually just drifting in front of
your eyes how do you tell the difference
by having multiple sensors
radar infrared sensors visual sighting
then you can tell how far this object is
away from you and then you can say that
no it's an optical illusion well
we do that now we have multiple
sightings of these objects by radar we
know how the velocity the distance
each time it comes out to be real
and so that's why we're scratching our
heads who has this capability and the
answer is we don't know
is there anything that's theoretical
that you're aware of that could be
applied like some from some other planet
or some other galaxy or whatever that
something that maybe we have theorized
that could be responsible for the way
these things are able to move
well you know when i talk to my friends
who are physicists like myself about
these things they sort of like laugh
giggle their eyes roll up to the heavens
and they say something very simple
that a rocket using conventional means
would take seventy thousand years to
reach us from the nearest star
therefore these objects cannot exist
seventy 000 years for a saturn rocket
traveling at 25 000 miles per hour to go
from a nearest star to the planet earth
that's why most scientists disregard
these sightings because they defy the
laws of einstein but isn't that kind of
silly isn't that kind of like saying
like you can't you know how long it
would take you to get a horse from los
angeles to sydney australia isn't that
kind of like saying that exactly and
that's why i say that that assumes that
these aliens or whatever
are maybe a hundred years more advanced
than us but open your mind to the
possibility that they are a thousand
years more advanced than us a thousand
years is nothing compared to the age of
the universe right the universe is about
13 uh
13 billion plus years old that's how the
age of the universe and so the age of a
civilization
just a few thousand years ahead of us
that is just a blink of an eye to the
universe itself
and once you go to higher energies the
laws of physics begin to break down the
laws of einstein and the laws of the
quantum theory break down as something
called the planck energy
why is that important that's what i do
for a living i work on something called
string theory which lives at the planck
energy the plunk energy is 10 to the 19
billion electron volts
that is a quadrillion times more
powerful than our most powerful atom
smasher outside geneva switzerland
any civilization that can harness the
planck energy would be able to become
masters of space and time
space and time as we know it become
unstable at the planck energy which is
far beyond anything that we can muster
here on the planet earth so we
physicists theorize how advanced do you
have to be to access the planck energy
well we rank them
the kardashev scale says that there
could be type 1 type 2 or type 3
civilizations
a type 1 civilization is maybe 100 years
more advanced than us to maybe a
thousand years
sort of like buck rogers or flash gordon
they control the weather
volcanoes earthquakes anything planetary
they control that's type one
then this type 2
type 2 is stellar
they harness the power of an entire star
like star trek star trek would be a
typical type 2 civilization
where they manipulate entire stars
then there's type three
type three is galactic they roam the
galactic space lanes they play with
black holes
like
like uh
the empire of the star wars series would
be a typical type 3 civilization
then the next question is what type do
you have to be to harness the planck
energy
the energy at which space and time
become unstable
where wormholes may develop gateways
through space and time portals through
empty space
you have to be type 2 or most likely
type 3.
then the next question is how long will
it take before you become type 3
well we are maybe a hundred years away
from being type one
we're maybe a few thousand years from
being from type two and we're maybe a
hundred thousand years being from being
type three
and a hundred thousand years is
nothing nothing on a galactic scale the
age of the universe is as i said over 13
billion years old
and so once a civilization reaches the
planck energy that is a type 3
civilization space and time
become your playground